et maintenant voici tom villa
[Musique]
demain
lui donner cette chance ouais
résume assez bien notre relation prendre
un enfant dans la main c'est vrai et
puis c'est bien yves duteil parce que ça
dynamise le début d'une émission non
mais c'est vrai alors présents mais
j'adore cette chanson prendre un enfant
par la main et finir en garde à vue
alors ce week-end c'est le second tour
des élections régionales donc on n'a pas
le droit de parler de politique
mais bon en français ils sont débiles
quand même vous avez vu ce qu'ils ont
fait vous avez vu pour qu'ils ont voté
sans déconner réveillez vous pouvez pas
faire ça relativise on fait gagner un
chien une gamine a un incroyable talent
sur m6 le connais bien je pense qu'il
faudrait retirer le droit de vote à ces
gens là
alors nolan ou zaoui bonsoir alors
retiré fiq nora est venue il ya dix mois
pour exactement la même promo du coup
j'ai ressorti vos vieilles fiche voix
roque comme ça à ces mêmes questions
j'en ai rajouté une pétition ou voilà ça
fait de redire ce spectacle à cape town
voilà comme ça
[Applaudissements]
alors selon marie-claire vous faites
partie des dix femmes les plus drôles de
france bravo voilà je savais pas qu'il y
en avait 10 mai non je sais que c'est
misogyne mais c'est que généralement
quand on dit d'une fille tiens elle est
marrante honnêtement il ya quand même
neuf chances sur dix pour que ça soit un
tromblon non mais c'est vrai
jean luc lemoine alors jean-luc la tyrie
en fait vu qu'il est venu il ya neuf
mois pour exactement la même promo du
coup voilà je ressens les vieilles fiche
aussi on s'emmerde train
toujours sympa ça c'est fait alors jean
luc je l adore dans touche pas à mon
poste il fait la rubrique des quatre
tiers alors pour ceux qui connaissent
pas en fait ils récupèrent les images
que personne ne voie pendant la pub et
il les montre à l'antenne alors le terme
technique c'est diffuser des offres ou
alors faire un coup de [ __ ] c'est au
choix non mais c'est une idée géniale et
quatre mois c'est pas que je veux pas le
faire c'est que je peux pas si je
diffusais non mais non si je diffuse qui
se passe pendant les pubs les
téléspectateurs vont être super déçu ça
ils pensent que ardisson c'est sexe
drogue et rock'n'roll alors qu'il n'y a
pas de rock'n'roll
remarqué il ya pas beaucoup de sacs sont
plus mais
très bien avec des les bons soirs alors
frédéric vous dirigez le magazine lui
voilà tenez je me permets senti cvc qui
jamais fait voilà parce que même si vous
cherchez un stagiaire qui est moi je
serais ravi de m'en branle de bosser
avec lui
[Applaudissements]
voilà
je vous la donne au cas où c'est ma
lettre de motivation voilà tony c'est
plutôt des stagiaires de sexe féminin
généralement fin c'est vrai c'est pas
grave comme par hasard
frédéric j'ai une très très bonne
nouvelle pour certains et une mauvaise
pour vous êtes papa depuis un mois voilà
toutes ses nuits blanches vous avez
passée en boîte de nuit en fait c'était
juste pour vous préparer à la paternité
puis depuis que vous avez une petite
fille maintenant les rôles sont inversés
c'est vous qui vous fait vomir dessus
franz olivier giesbert attire donc nous
voir pour son film sur chirac mais il ya
un petit débat juste après donc c'est
quoi le débat pour ou contre
l'euthanasie ça je sais pas j'ai pas
drôle non c'est pas bien méchant soir
juste un truc qu'il ya un truc que je
comprends pas il ya quinze jours vous
avez fait un documentaire sur les bêtes
d'abattoir aujourd'hui vous venez à de
faire un documentaire sur jacques chirac
un nom mais c'est bien c'est un
documentaire sur la viande et un autre
sur les légumes ça c'est cool
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
thierry ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser nos runs louis n'aura vous êtes
d'origine syrienne du coup l'été vous
partez quand même en vacances au bled ou
pas
franz olivier giesbert ben tous les
anciens présidents étaient des hommes à
femmes mitterrand chirac sarkozy même
hollande alors pourquoi alain juppé
s'acharne encore
on est souvent surpris quand on suit les
choses de près en ce sens surprise des
gens on pensait pas qu'il y avait des
histoires et y en a quand même je
m'attends pas sinon je pense aussi aux
plus folles tout est là on allait
longtemps après de la balance et je vous
souhaite une excellente émission mais
pour moi et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu